je viens paris en week end et je trouve
que ce mélange de gens de genres de
styles d'univers c'est ce qui me
convient donc je décide de partir
donc je quitte ma famille je quitte mes
certitudes je pars avec mon petit copain
de l'époque on s'installe à paris
[Musique]
j'avais rencontré j'étais au lycée et
lui était pilote de chasse et
est très beau et il voulait être
mannequin donc quand on est parti à
paris il a démissionné et de l'armée et
on est parti ensemble à paris et je les
accompagnais pour pourvoir les agences
de mannequins parce qu'il veut et
mannequin et puis donc je me tenais un
peu en retrait et quand je suis allé
chez élite
il est venu d'aller voir les bookers
qu'ils ont vu qu'ils ont dit mais vous
mademoiselle venez tout ça je suis
rapproché on ne voulait pas être
mannequin et finalement ils m'ont pris
moi et pas lui ce qui a provoqué pas mal
de problèmes dans le couple aimant et
c'est comme ça que j'ai commencé chez
élite et c'était j'ai vécu j'ai vécu un
an mannequin chez élite j'ai détesté
parce que d'abord j'ai du caractère et
me dire c'est la femme-objet c'était
compliqué pour moi à gérer tuer ton bras
comme si machin j'en regarde la caméra
fait l'amour avec la caméra
moi je rigolais jeu mais sa tarte
c'était l'époque où ou quand on défile
il fallait faire la gueule malgré tout
le temps je voyais pas pourquoi il
fallait faire la gueule et puis je
comprenais pas la jalousie déficit pas
ma mentalité du tout et il y avait des
histoires qu'elle se faisait des
croche-pieds qu'elle renverse et le
vernis sur la robe de mariée parce
qu'elle était vexé que c'était pas être
qu'il peut apporter mais des trucs j'ai
halluciné complètement j'ai pas aimé du
tout et en même temps voilà il y avait
un monde comme ça les gens qui sortent
elles soir les filles qui couchait avec
des mecs vieux qui était puissant jeu
j'étais très observatrice de tout ça et
je me disais mais c'est pas mon monde à
six mois avant j'étais au lycée à nancy
en plus j'avais les cheveux courts
j'étais métis je connaissais tu savais
pas trop que j'étais jolie parce qu'on
ne l'avait pas trop dit je n'avais pas
les codes
j'avais pas les jeudis vêtements j'avais
pas l'attitude un peu pincé j'avais été
j'avais rien de tous les autres et je me
sentais mais vraiment le vilain petit
canard quoi
non c'était à la fois risible à la fois
très désespérant et au bout d'un an j'ai
démissionné
j'ai passé de l'autre côté je suis
devenu bookeuse je dis bien fait chier
pas vrai
[Musique]
comme beaucoup de personnes je
n'arrivais pas à tomber enceinte
et donc j'ai fait plein d'examen et je
suis tombé sur plein de médecins qui
m'ont dit des choses atroces avec plus
ou moins de tact et pendant longtemps je
pensais que j'étais stérile et puis
finalement j'ai été opérée geste suffit
d'échanger tout arrêter et
et comme souvent quand on lâche aussi là
je suis tombée enceinte sans le savoir
et
et voilà mais ça a été après deux ans à
deux ans de traitement assez intensif et
de douter
je ne me voyais pas ne pas être maman
quoi tout ce parcours du combattant pour
devenir maman m'a fait prendre
conscience que que finalement
devenir parent c'était ça pouvait être
quelque chose de très viscéral et je me
suis dit personne n'a le droit de
décider pour quelqu'un d'autre s'il a le
droit ou pas d'avoir un enfant et moi
qui suis issu d'une famille de femmes je
n'avais pas de pair la violence du
discours
un papa une maman je la prenais aussi de
plein fouet parce que ça veut dire quoi
que je pas équilibrée parce que j'ai pas
eu papa ben je pense que si donc voilà
je crois qu'à un moment donné
voilà mon expérience personnelle sais
que je peux être très virulente dans ce
combat là
[Musique]
j'ai ressenti ce besoin là en 2015 alors
pourquoi d'acheter ma résidence
principale et d'entamer une thérapie
peut-être pour accepter une certaine
introspection que je refusais aussi pour
préparer l'émission une ambition intime
que je tournais à ce moment là j'avais
besoin de comprendre le mécanisme de la
thérapie à quel moment vous êtes
confiance à son thérapeute actuellement
la parole se libère et j'avais besoin de
théoriser ça pour réussir à faire sortir
des choses très personnelles de gens qui
étaient très claquemuré dans un discours
et qui n'avaient pas l'habitude de se
livrer qu'il faisait pour la première
fois publiquement
donc c'était aussi professionnel c'était
une belle aventure en fait de commencer
ça j'ai jamais arrêté je continue à voir
un thérapeute tous les quinze jours et
je crois que ça m'a aidé dans ma façon
d'être aussi avec les gens de mon
travail avec mon enfant
avec les amis avec tout le monde je me
sens beaucoup plus apaisé et
et voilà c'est c'est important et au et
au final je me suis rendu compte aussi
que quelque part
la parole était vraiment libératrice
pour tout le monde et que j'en faisais
mon travail depuis le début et que
c'était c'était ça donc il fallait bien
que j'y passe aussi